chinese naval vessels have been pulling
floating objects out of the Indian Ocean
in the area where possible debris from
the missing plane had earlier been
spotted from the air but so far the crew
have not found anything relevant there
were visuals from from five aircraft of
debris in the ocean unfortunately
despite the presence of some six vessels
in and around the new search area we
have not yet been able to recover any
debris so that that task continues the
search area has been shifted north from
the basis of a new analysis of radar and
satellite data search aircraft are
spending hours out over the Indian Ocean
crews report sightings of objects near
the surface but the area to be covered
is vast about as big as Poland
Malaysia's acting Transport Minister
informs relatives daily of progress they
hang on every detail there is still hope
he didn't say all the passengers are
dead those young would you check out
would ya some relatives say they will
not give up hope until there is physical
proof that mh370 crashed